Bonsoir a tous
*Bruit d'iron man stylé*
Je suis Iron Man
Oh put**.. J'adore ce masque ! ahaha
Les amis aujourd'hui on va faire une expérience sociale *rire d'homme constipé*
Aujourd'hui on est sur "Dude, stop"
Arrête mec ! Voila ce que ça veut dire en Français ..
C'est un jeu dans lequel on va être face a des situations un peu "nawaq"
Et selon ce qu'on fera dans tel ou tel situation, on va être rangé dans une catégorie de personne
"START"
Oh, bien tu es là.
J’espère  juste que tu ne fais pas partis de tous ces joueurs qui adorent : Toucher traîner ou tout balancer ..
Noooon... On est pas comme ça ..
Peu importe, Let's play !
Aller jouons ..
Ok première situation : On a des cartons .. "UP"
Il faut je pense soulever les cartons
Et en faire quelque chose
Le mettre de côté ?
Le lancer dans le vide on peut pas ..
L'envoyer en l'air
Mais est-ce que? Je viens pas de dire que ... Bref oublies
Bah ouais mon gars, on fait partie des gens qui adorent "toucher des choses"
Dans les jeux vidéos là tout faire chier et créer des bugs
Mais le livre des règles disait précisément que tu ne devais pas faire ça!
Regarde ici, j'ai marqué la page pour toi.
Montre-moi la page, que t'as marqué ..
C'est ça ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire. Faut retirer le marque-page ?
*Rire fier de sa blague*
On manque de respect à un ordinateur mon gars
-Aller regarde donc cette peinture parfaitement réalisé, et relaxe toi, ok ?
*son horreur*
Il faut la faire tourner ? Il faut faire quoi !
J'étais en train de faire ma blague où le gars fait une bêtise mais il y a aucune bêtise
pour la retirer il doit y avoir un angle où on peut la retirer j'pense , t'sais
nan mais attends retirer un tableau c'est facile, c'est le mettre qui est chiant
parce que tu vois pas le clou et tu galères
musique trololo
*musique stressante*
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec ce tableau ?
j'peux pas l'balancer, il est accrocher au mur, et j'le touche...ah
qu'est-ce que j'ai fais de spécial ? je sais meme pas ce que j'ai fais il s'est passé l'truc j'sais meme pas s'que j'ai fais
oh tu commence vraiment a m'tendre,avant d'en finir faisons un p'tit break dans la salle de bain
Oh !!!
Qu'est-ce-que je dois faire pour t'emmerder ?
'Faut soulever la cuvette ?
Tirer la chasse d'eau en boucle ?
Casser une dalle ?
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je f...
aaah, et bien soulever la cuvette, c'est bien ça
faut que je mette un truc dedans, mais quoi?
ah, soulever les deux?!
Oh come On, pas aux toilettes des femmes
mais c'est toi qui m'a emmené là!
attend le mec!
c'est lui le guide pourrit et c'est moi
qu'il enguele, j'hallucine
allez donne moi mon trophée (X2)
je veux qu'il brille hein
ah super merci mec
c'est vraiment gentil
il est déguelasse...
Voilà ce que tu gagnes
pour etre un Monstre!
Merci, bravo! c'est bien... c'est bien de crtiqiuer.
hey, tu as déjà compléter le premier pack
Retourne en arrière et passe au deuxième
pack
Retour ou alors va te faire foutre...
Va te faire foutre!
Ah le batard!!
Oh non!
j'ai fais le malin...
j'ai tellement fait le malin
*musique héroïque*
*bruit robotique*
facile ce jeu
Oh non putain!
oh non cette phase elle est relou
vas-y j'ai le temps de sauver des gens!
*musique héroique*
*bruit robotique*
c'est bon, j'ai sauver
des tas de personnes
allez il y a plus rien à faire ici, maintenant dégage!
ouhhhhhhh
*musique Héroïque*
ferme ta gueule!
On dirais que j'ai 7 ans mon gars
Alors, est-ce qu'on a gagné la deuxième coupe?
c'est ça qu'on veut savoir actuellement
ah du coup j'ai une petite coupe
Pour être têtu et avoir terminé le pack deux fois
il y a pas un deuxième "secret award" si je le fais trois fois?
Non! Non!
trop la flemme, j'ai bloqué pendant 10min sur le tableau là!
pack 2, c'est parti!
mec, arrête cette stupide violence
tu n'as pas besoin d'être aussi vilain
on peut toujours sauver ton âme
Pas aujourdhui!
Ouai , pas aujourd'hui! plus tard mais ...
On verra ça un autre jour
il y a une lettre
je mets le timbre sur la lettre
je suis pas vilain hein en faisant ça
c'est bien normal
*bruit applaudissement*
tout droit là où il faut!
non, c'est bon!
On est gentil!
là il y a une verte, qu'est ce qu'on fait?
On la met dans celle des... rouges! (rire)
faut être un putain de provocateur pour faire ça!
en plus moi j'adore quand tout est symétrique
et parfait
tu sais des fois j’aligne les choses comme ça, comme un attardé
sinon, je suis perturbé.
ah c'est humiliant..
ah on choisit une police d'écriture!
Arial , Times New Roman , Comic sans ou Calibri
Si je dis Comic sans, j'suis un... j'suis un connard ?
Allez , la Comic sans , on adore cette écriture *Rire*
"NO"
Il a même pas argumenté.
On a ici une sandale , un pied nue et une chaussette
Qu'est ce qu'on fait ?
On met la chaussette sur le pied
Et on met la sandale sur le pied
"Sérieusement ?" *Rire*
Mec c'est un style de ouf
C'est un style de malade
Quand tu l'as , tu te sens vraiment bien
*Bruit du passage au niveau suivant*
*Musique du jeu*
*Rire*
Ah c'est horrible*Rire*
Ca m'a démangé de le faire
"NO.NO.NO.NO !" "NOOOOOOOO
Ah putain , on avais... on avais un bon 4 lignes là mon gars
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
C'est quoi ça ?
WTF ?
"Safety First"
Ah ! Genre j'ai mis la pièce la plus haute dedans donc c'est la moins risqué
Donc j'suis un gars bien. C'est ça ?
'Tain il juge *incompréhensible* ce jeu hein ça y va
Ah le jugement on y est , on est là
"Dude , Stop"
Ah ok , c'est une fausse page de Steam Greenlight du jeu "Dude,Stop"
En fait pour ceux qui savent pas les développeurs ils peuvent mettre leur jeu sur Steam Greenlight
Et en fait les gens votent pour les meilleurs jeux. Et ensuite les jeux se retrouve sur le
Steam , le vrai
Achèterais-tu ce jeu sur Steam ?
Euh... "Yes" ou "Demande moi plus tard". Demande moi plus tard.
*Son d'une femme qui crie*
On y sera un jour *Rire*
"Vote 2016"
Une case ou y'à rien , une case où...y'à une banane jaune , une case où y'à rien , une case où y'a...
AH ! C'est Trump !
C'est ça !
Du coup on sais qui a gagné à l'heure actuelle donc euh...
Allez bah trump
*Rire*
"Ce clique m'a donné le cancer"
Ah ouais ? Et alors quand il a gagné les élections présidentielle ça t'a donné quoi mon gars ?
T'es mort instantanément du coup ?
Oh c'est l'heure de vérité , ATTENTION !
*Musique Héroique*
Êtes-vous prêt à savoir si on est un mosntre ?
On a fait 60% de réponses de monstre
Et 40% de réponse de bonnes personnes
Bah ça va on a un bon ratio
"Complète 80% des niveaux en étant un monstre"
Pour avoir la coupe des mon... du monstre.
Et ben comme j'adore les coupes , et ben je vais le refaire
Parce que je veux les coupes
Et la coupe que je veux en particulier c'est la coupe de cheveux
Parce que là... C'est chaud
Voilà , je suis fier. Aurevoir.
*Musique encourageante*
Hein ? Attendez y'a un truc qu'on avais même pas fais tout à l'heure !
C'est quoi ça ?
"Yes ! C'est une récompense pour les fourmis"
Ah c'est une coupe bonus qu'on vient d'avoir !
Ah nan ok c'est la coupe , du coup quand on a fait 80% de réponse de monstre
C'est une toute petite coupe euh... Une couplette finalement
Allez on va faire les bonnes réponses maintenant
*Musique des années 50*
Eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeet l'heure de la coupe
Oh elle est belle ! Elle est très belle
Ca me fait penser aux coupes euh.. qu'on gagner dans Mario Kart à l'ancienne
Et on été tout content quand tu l'a eu
En mode 150cc , toi même tu sais
"C'est pour toi , toi qui est une personne totalement normale *Rire*
Et il fait que nous rabaisser ce jeu , il brise notre égaux.
Notre petit égaux de YouTuber prout prout là il est brisé en mille.
Et ça c'est quoi ? Faut accepter d'aller dans la.. Bon allez !
Voulez-vous visiter la page Steam Greenlight ?
Oui.
Ah l'esprit de compétition il est là !
Ah nan mais nous on est un peu comme Tony Yoka et Teddy Rinner
Tu vois ce que je veux dire
On a juste pas le physique
Et ben voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo !
Sur "Dude,Stop" Un petit jeu très sympa vraiment
N’hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Ça me faisait marrer ce principe de "LE JEU TE JUGE SELON TES CHOIX"
Tu est un FDP parce que tu as mis le bonbon vert
Dans la coupe du bonbon rouge
Eh tu connais pas ma vie tu peux pas... tu sais pas qui je suis
Tu peux pas me juger, pourquoi tu s’éteint ah d'accord
Tu me manque du respect
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regarder
Portez-vous bien
Chio tous le monde
Pisse (MDR)
Voilà j'peux pas voler parce que j'ai que le casque
Donc c'est un peu nul quoi